One of the problems with climate change
is that human beings like to react to
things that are immediate
and right in front of them.
And I think for us it's very
difficult to see the future,
especially if it's inconvenient as,
especially if it does
something to inconvenience or
get in the way of our day to
day routine. And that seems to be
what happened, what's happening here.
And that seems to me,
excuse me,
it seems to me to be why people
are so willing to dismiss it.
Uh, so flippantly because
in front of them right now,
it's not an issue in front of them
right now. This very second is very day.
I'm going to go to Starbucks. It's right
there. It's open. Look, I'm outside.
It's 65 degrees out. Global
warming's not a problem. Yeah, yeah.
No, I think that's, I mean, totally true.
And I feel it in my own life. Like I,
I mean I've been living, I've been
working in this material so long,
I know it so deeply and yet when I
look out the window I'm like, you know,
things are fine. Yeah. And I think that
has a really powerful anchoring effect.
Like we expect the world of the future
to look like the world as it does today.
But all the science says that's totally
naive and we're going to have at least
twice as much warming as
we've had to this point.
And I think we need to think about the
future of the world in those terms.
Like what, it will be a two degrees
or three degrees at four degrees.
But it's not just like the immediacy.
I think we have so many biases that may,
like we want to be optimistic about
the future. We have a status quo bias.
We don't want to change things. We think
that will be complicated and expensive.
We have a hard time holding big
ideas in our head like that.
The entire planet is like
subject to these forces. Um,
I mean the list goes on and on in the
book I have a little riff where I say,
you know, there's this new not
so new now, 30, 40 year, um,
discipline in economics,
behavioral economics,
which is about all of our cognitive
biases. How we can't really see the world.
Every single one makes it harder
to see climate. There's this, um,
he's actually an English professor
named Timothy Morton who wrote,
who wrote a book about, um, climate
and he calls it a hyper object,
which is like,
it's a,
it's a phenomenon that's so big that we
can't actually hold it in our heads at
once.
We can only see it.
It's like if you imagine seeing a four
dimensional object in three dimensional
space,
it's that kind of thing where you can
only see it at an angle only partially
climate changes.
So all encompassing that we
can't comprehend it properly.
Um,
but I think that's all,
all of those things are reasons that we
need to be listening to the scientists
and what they're projecting.
Not to say that everything they're saying
is going to come true will come true.
Exactly as they predict it.
Obviously that's not how science works.
It gets revised. Some things are
alarmist and things are extreme,
something's just wrong.
But you know,
I've been really working on this stuff
for a couple of years and the number of
papers I've read that show that make me
have a more optimistic idea about the
future of climate.
I could count on two hands,
the number of papers I've read that make
me have a bleaker view of the future.
It's in the thousands.
And when you look at the totality of that,
whether the six climate driven natural
disasters prediction is going to pan out
exactly as those authors say, who knows?
But when you see, you know, so many,
so many terrifying studies
that you could fill.
Like I did a 300 page book with them.
You realize that like there's a huge
margin for error and it would like,
we would still be really in bad
shape. You know, is there a,
I mean,
I'm sure there have been some studies
that made mistakes in terms of like past
studies have projected that by now
we'd all be dead. Um, are those,
those seem to be a problem with this
whole concept we have of wrapping our head
around it and if we find anything
that we could point to that say,
oh way back in the 80s, they said we
all be dead by now and we're fine,
we're going to be fine. That kind of
thing is that that is an issue. Correct?
Totally. Yeah. There was, um,
there was a really famous book in the
Middle Of the 20th century called the
population bomb. So this is a
guy named Paul Ehrlich Ehrlich,
who he was like,
you know,
the world just cannot
support this many people.
Like if we get to 8 billion people,
there just won't be enough food.
There won't be, you know, the,
the planet can sustain that.
And he's often pointed to as this sort
of like profit of dooms day that and his
prophecy totally didn't work out because
we had this thing that's called the
green revolution. Basically we figured
out ways to make crops way, way,
way more productive
and that's encouraging.
Human civilization does that a lot.
We figure our way out of
Fox holes all the time.
But that revolution was
literally like one dude,
Norman Borlaug who figured out how to
grow crops differently and one guy,
one set of innovations and he completely
transformed the whole fate of the
planet. What did he do?
He just basically did, um,
like genetically modified crops before,
like the, you know, before the name,
it was like, um, he could golden
rice guy. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
And um,
and you know,
the whole developing world benefited
enormously and you're still seeing that
today. Like we see all these charts
that, you know, so much less poverty,
so much less infant mortality and
developing world and that's great.
That's like incredible progress.
But a lot of that has,
was powered by the industrialization
of those countries,
so that bill is going to
come do going forward. Um,
and you know, I think like when
you look at climate change,
you know,
if there was just one threat,
like let's take agriculture since we're
talking about agriculture estimates,
say that, um, if we continue on the path
we're on, by the end of the century,
grain yields would be half as
productive as they are today just by the
temperature effect.
So we'd have just as much land,
just as much grain crops as we have now,
but the food we get from it,
we'd only get half as much as we
get today. What's the cross of that?
It's just the temperature effects
plus the temperature alone. Wow.
I mean there are other impacts
to on food. Um, like insects,
there's hotter temperatures means more
insects, which is bad for crops. Um,
carbon has a complicated
to to crop growth,
like in some plants grow bread
or better with more carbon,
but actually they're like the weeds and
the ones that we like to eat don't grow
better with more carbon. Um, and
you know, by the end of the century,
so we could have half as much grain and
we could have 50% more people than we
have right now. Um, now there's
a way you could imagine, oh,
well maybe there'll be
another Norman Borlaug,
maybe he'll figure out a way through that.
But when you look across the spectrum,
it's like agriculture. It's, you know,
conflict for every half degree of warming,
you need to get between
10 and 20% more war.
So if we get to the end of the century,
we're going to have more than
twice as much wars. We have to,
and this is projected because of battles
over resources, mainly that famines,
droughts, um, whether,
you know, weather impacts,
basically everything about
unstable societies get
stressed by temperature eyes.
The Syrian civil war was,
you know,
it wasn't single leak caused
by climate change, but it was,
that's one of the causes.
There was a drought and that produced it.
And that conflict,
it's not just at the level of
nation states or even civil war,
it's also at the level of individual.
So if you look at crime statistics,
when temperatures go up, there's
more murder, there's more rape.
People get admitted to mental hospitals
more when there's, when it's warmer out.
Um, babies develop less well in
the womb when it's hotter out.
If there's for every day over 90
degrees that have babies in the womb,
you can see those days in that baby's
lifetime earnings and we're living,
we're going to be living on a
planet that's considerably warmer,
that's going to have real dramatic
effects on everything. Um, air pollution,
there's a big study that I write about
in the book that's totally alarming and
eye opening,
just between 1.5 degrees and two degrees
of warming just through the effects of
air pollution would cause at one
half degree of warming would cause an
additional hundred 53 million deaths,
which is 25 holocausts.
That's just air pollution,
just between 1.5 and two degrees.
And two degrees for me is
our best case scenario.
So our best case scenario is 25 holocausts
worth of death from air pollution.
And that sounds terrifying. People
when I say that to them, they're like,
Holy Shit, how could we
possibly that's unconscionable.
But already 9 million people are dying
every year from air pollution and we
don't pay attention to it.
So I think the likeliest outcome,
even as we enter into this
like climate health scape,
is that we find ways to turn away and
not look at like the real pain of people,
especially in the developing world. But
to answer your earlier question, you know,
like you can imagine
agriculture getting figured out,
but when you see just how many impacts
there are, it's like it's everywhere.
Everything will be changed.
And it just makes the challenge that
much bigger and more complicated because
how he, you know, how are you going
to solve the conflict problem?
How are you going to solve the problem
of having 30% less economic growth?
You know,
like I said,
that's an impact that's twice as big
as the great depression and it would be
permanent, um, $600 trillion in,
in climate damage as twice as much
wealth as exist in the world today. Um,
and that's just, you know,
then you deal with it, right?
Refugees, food. I mean it's,
it's, it's so all
encompassing. And I think, um,
that's another reason why we don't
want to look at it closely because
terrifying.
Well there,
there's also a matter of how it's being
projected to the public, right? Like in,
in certain circles, particularly
right wing circles. Uh,
there,
there are people that are trying to
paint this with rose colored glasses,
right?
They're trying to maximize short term
profits and sort of dismiss the risks of
climate change and dismiss the risks of,
or rather the impact of our,
uh,
what we've done in terms of raising
the carbon in the atmosphere.
There's some people that point to that
like this, this is nonsense science.
This has been disproven.
There's a few people like
that, but it's an overwhelming,
the overwhelming consensus of scientists
who study this are terrified of it.
Yeah. I would say there was some recent
report that said now past the standard of
physics that like climate science
is now more reliable than physics.
Um, bus hilarious. But
you know, the, um, to the,
to the deniers, you say
things like, you know,
the planet was hotter than this before.
That's true. Yeah. Dinosaurs lived here.
Humans, we're not here. I mean, if we're
four degrees warmer for the last time,
the plan was four degrees warmer, there
were palm trees in the Arctic. Um, what's,
yeah,
really,
we've already exited the entire window
of temperature that enclose all of human
history.
So the planet is now warmer than it
ever has been when humans were around to
walk on it.
Which means to me,
it's an open question whether humans would
have ever evolved in the first place.
And this is all from the industrial
revolution from then on. Yeah. And uh,
yeah, and like, and to that question,
it's like there are people who say
there's some natural warming going on.
I don't think that's true. I think
most scientists would say it isn't.
But I also think if what we're
seeing is natural warming,
that should terrify us even more because
it would mean that it's outside of our
control.
And if we're really heading down the path
that we're heading down and we have no
control over it,
that's even more scary.
It should be a comfort that we're doing
it because it means we can stop doing it
right.